what are the most terrifying traumatic
events in the history of Harry Potter
The Boy Who Lived he's been through it
y'all at number one we have visions from
Voldemort okay maybe the first time it
got a little weird but he ended up
getting this so many times throughout
the series I feel like I'm gonna start
with a B tier we may move these around
as we go but right now B tier on Visions
from Voldemort the visit to godrics
hollow with Hermione okay reading this
for the first time I can't tell you how
far my jaw was dropped opening what was
her name not Bertha jorkens but filled a
bag shot nagini is essentially wearing
bathilda bag shot as a suit oh my
goodness I mean putting yourself in
Harry's shoes I guess by that point with
all he had faced it probably wouldn't
fit in the realm of s tier which is
saying something so if it were me
personally it would be S tier for me I'm
terrified of snakes but for Harry I
think probably a tier is where it would
be Dementors near the lake okay this is
interesting that they have Dementors
listed separately because I'm guessing
yeah we've got them into our in a train
Dementors on the Quidditch pitch okay so
we might have the Dementors ranked
differently based on where Harry ran
into them so this one the Dementors near
the lake had the added fear of the fact
that Sirius is there and Harry is trying
to rescue Sirius at this point he knows
he's his Godfather he knows that he
actually didn't turn over his parents
he's faced the Dementors a little bit at
this point so it's not quite as
terrifying but I still think I Gotta
Give it an AIDS here a troll in the
dungeon okay maybe you want to use a
first year troll would have been higher
but at the end trolls D tier right there
the ministry battle plus series is death
ooh man okay we might have our first s
tier here anytime you have a death
especially if someone that close to you
after Harry had already lost his parents
at a young age and he had finally found
that someone who he could look to as a
father figure he finally found somewhere
that you know he really thought he was
going to be able to have a normal life
and then have it all taken away from him
in the way it was taken away from him
when he kind of led to it happening it's
really unfortunate so it's got to be
asked here in terms of how traumatic
okay Ron leaving the horcrux hunt oh man
your best friend
your best friend leaves you at a time
when you need it most I mean I I can't
put it up there at s tier with Sirius
death because of the fact that I mean at
least he knew Ron was still alive at
least he knew there's a chance that Ron
will turn around and come back at some
point which of course he eventually did
I'm gonna put it in a tier from now
though a tier for now escaping from a
werewolf okay Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban they find out their
Professor Remus Lupine is in fact a
werewolf they have to get away from him
ah b-tier Maybe
again I know that's crazy considering
everything that Harry ends up going
through I would put it above uh Visions
from Voldemort though the horcrux hunt
Okay that includes a lot of things
though right I mean that includes a lot
of this that includes Ron leaving that
includes the visit to godrics hollow you
know what I'm gonna put this one down
here at the end and come back to that
one because I want to see how many of
these end up actually being part of the
horror correction I don't really feel
like it's fair to have that
all-encompassing horcrux hunt so we'll
see the LIE campaign and the prophet
against him ooh I mean it was definitely
tough at the time and it was hard for
him to go through that especially in
that book and in some ways it almost
might be worse than something like I
mean you think about escaping from a
werewolf once you get away that's that's
it you know it's done but the LIE
campaign that went on for a while oh man
but in terms of traumatic though I mean
when I think of traumatic I think of
just like this this incredible fear that
you have in the moment so I think this
one would be a little more long-lasting
Sirius breaking into their dormitory
with a knife oh again like at the time
that was so creepy oh man I'm kind of
thinking maybe we bump Ron down a little
bit Ron leaving the horcrux hunt I mean
that was traumatic but traumatic in
different ways I'm gonna put serious at
B2 here and then we might go back and
kind of rearrange these at the end as we
go okay the Gringotts break-in oh man so
again I mean this is part of the horcrux
hunt so they go in they have to get into
bellatrix's Vault they have to use
imperio along the way I mean I guess you
could argue whether they had to or not
but they did again I'm feeling beatier
on this one Umbridge or the other name
they have here air detentions definitely
annoying and definitely something that
Harry would never forget but I don't
think it elevates to any of these things
but again though again here I go talking
myself out of it this wasn't a one-time
deal you know serious breaking into
their dormitory with a knife yes that
singular event is probably more
traumatic than any one of umbridge's
detentions but the fact that you have
all those detentions that stacked up on
one another I'm almost thinking about
dropping down escaping from aware wolf
because I don't remember them being too
freaked out after that again there were
so many other things that happened in
that scene involving Sirius involving
wormtail that the werewolf was kind of
like the secondary thing that happened
right oh lupine's a werewolf well guess
what Sirius Black was not responsible
for my parents death bronze rat wormtail
has been hiding all along I think that
is arguably more traumatic so you know
what let's just go ahead and drop this
down and we'll see we'll see we might
end up moving that one oh and of course
here we go reveal of scours being
Pettigrew
I do I think that was more traumatic
than trying to escape from the werewolf
but I don't know that I would elevate it
to here let's let's put it right here
the curse broom Ah d-tier that's that's
nothing compared to this other stuff the
prophecy wow okay so the prophecy
obviously a very big deal in Harry's
life although I would kind of argue he
sort of already knew I mean we
definitely knew that it was gonna have
to come down to something like that I'm
gonna say C tier on the prophecy for now
Battle of Hogwarts wow okay that has to
be S tier I mean they lost so many
people right literally everything of the
series built up to that moment and that
moment affected Harry for the rest of
his life Death Eaters after the
Quidditch World Cup okay this is C tier
again in the moment it was pretty freaky
and crazy however at the end of the day
Harry still had a lot of people helping
him out detention in the Forbidden
Forest oh man so you gotta think this is
back to first year Harry he's just
getting exposed to all the stuff right
here I'm kind of hovering between C and
B right here of course they run into a
version of Voldemort taking out the
Unicorn yeah let's go with B tier on
this one indirect murder attempt on
Katie that was pretty freaky that was
absolutely pretty freaky but it didn't
happen to Harry or anyone who was
immediately close to him I mean I know
obviously he was close to Katie from
quidditch but it wasn't like you know
Ron or Hermione and then we have dying
why okay yeah
sure it gets in more traumatic or
terrifying than that but if we think
about Harry's mental state and the lead
up to that moment he was I think
prepared you know he knew what he had to
do and it's been a while since I've read
the book I don't know if he really knew
what exactly was going to come after if
he was going to have a choice to come
back or not I could possibly be
persuaded to drop this one down to an a
given how he was prepared going into
that and I think expected that he was
gonna have to do something like that but
still all in all it's it's hard for
anything to rake higher than dying in
terms of how terrifying it would be
Dementors on the train okay if I
remember correctly this was Harry's
first encounter with the Dementors I
mean it's got to be pretty close to S
tier maybe it's at the front of the a
tier here we'll leave it there for now
and see what we run into fight with
quarrel okay Harry in his first year
this teacher who's been instructing him
in defense against the dark arts his
whole entire year has Voldemort in the
back of his head that my friends is
pretty terrifying for a 10 year old who
just started school cool I guess he was
actually 11 at the time because of his
age and because of the fact that I think
that's the point when he realized wow
yes I found out about this incredible
amazing world however there was someone
who is hunting me and is probably going
to keep hunting me for the rest of my
life or their life whichever one ends
first I'm gonna put that up here on a
tier and right now we'll put it just
after the Dementors and just before Ron
indirect murder attempt on Ron okay we
just talked about Katie Bell how that
one we put at C but Ron
oh man you're it's your best friend
right so I think that's got to be an a
tier Malfoy Manor though that was a
pretty intense moment obviously they
just narrowly are able to escape that
and then of course it ends with Dobby's
death which was a very very difficult
time for Harry I'm gonna say a high beat
here on that one high B tier dementor is
on the Quidditch pitch again it's your
worst fear this one I'm gonna say
slightly less dramatic simply because
the fact that he was playing quidditch
at the time also he had Dumbledore and
all the other powerful Wizards right
there so I think at the end of the day
in the back of his mind he probably knew
that something major wasn't going to
happen to him even if he was terrified
in the moment Dobby's visit okay that
one's D tier it definitely messed things
up for him and set things on a difficult
path for book two but it's nothing
compared to these others the cave with
Voldemort's tour cracks oh my gosh
having to
basically force your Mentor the person
who you have been learning from and have
been really idolizing who you see as the
most powerful wizard on the planet to
force him to keep drinking a potion that
quite literally seems to be killing him
man that would be an incredibly
difficult thing to do and honestly
looking at a lot of these that we have
in AIDS here right now I mean I think
it's more traumatic than that more
traumatic than that more traumatic than
the fight with quarrel more traumatic
than the Dementors near the lake because
of how direct it was that he was right
there and he was the one who was having
to force that into Dumbledore visit to
godrick's hollow with Hermione though
this is actually so tough this kid had a
lot happening to him a lot of bad things
happening to him oh man you know what
I'm gonna put it just behind Dementors
just above godric's Hollow because he
was a little bit older for godrics
hollow and at that point he knew how
crazy and messed up this world was the
first task okay yeah I rate that kind of
down here like escaping from a werewolf
something like that at Death Eaters
after quidditch World Cup yeah in that
range crashing a car into the Whomping
Willow probably in this same area as
well although maybe we drop it down here
maybe that one's D I mean that probably
isn't as traumatic as something like the
prophecy you know
let's put it at d
oh Dumbledore's death okay they actually
did list that one out separately I still
don't think it would change the k for me
though because again the fact that he
was having to force the Dumbledore the
potion and then you have all the
inferior I mean literally dead bodies
rising up from the water I'm gonna keep
that one there but Dumbledore's death oh
dude here's the question does
Dumbledore's death Elevate to S tier I'm
trying to think of how it affected him
how it impacted him and how terrifying
it was I mean in the moment he couldn't
do anything he did get pretty mad at
Snape didn't he I'm gonna say s tier and
we may go back and rearrange these here
shortly the second task underwater I'm
gonna put that one as a little bit more
traumatic than the first task simply
because his best friends were involved
death day party I mean was that really
that I guess it's kind of weird but by
that point they knew about ghosts in The
Wizarding World so I'm gonna say that's
down here in D tier the wedding plus the
ministry falling oh yeah that's really
when they had to go on the run when
everything kicked off in terms of
terrifying slash dramatic though let's
say C tier third task without the
kidnapping part okay that's very
important if it's without the kidnapping
without everything that happened in the
graveyard then I'm probably just gonna
put it down here let's see was it worse
than the second task I actually think
the second task might have been a little
bit more traumatic simply because it was
his best friends all right Chamber of
Secrets ambassilisk ooh again not a huge
fan of snakes here for me as a reader
that was ridiculously terrifying we also
have Ginny Weasley who Harry's trying to
save at the moment at least a tier maybe
s tier I mean the fact that you have
learned a giant snake has been living
under the school the whole time that
it's after anyone who is muggle born is
absolutely insane oh and it just so
happens to have your best friend's
little sister who's eventually going to
be your wife one day you don't know that
yet though I'm gonna give it a high a
tier just behind the cave and just
behind mentors in a train hedwig's death
oh that was a tough one and it was a
sign of things to come in Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows that is for sure
I definitely don't think it affected
Harry more than Dobby's death though and
if we're including Dobby's death in
Malfoy Manor you know what Malfoy Manor
I'm Gonna Bump Malfoy Manor up to eight
here because we have indirect murder
attempt on Ron well that was like an
indirect attempt Malfoy Manor though
Dobby actually dies right here
Dobby actually dies okay let's slot it
in just behind the mentors the dementor
one is really difficult for me to rape
the graveyard okay they do list that one
out separately Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire in the graveyard with
wormtail who is in the process of
Reviving Voldemort bringing him back to
life Flesh Blood and Bone I will never
forget reading that book and just how
fearful Harry was in that moment when
the baby is Dropped In The Cauldron and
he just keeps thinking please let it
jump please let it jump please let it
drown it's just this
Terror I mean it is an absolute Terror
in that moment and because of that I
mean you have someone like Cedric who's
not really a friend but someone who you
have grown to respect throughout this
whole process throughout this whole
tri-wizard tournament you see them just
instantly taken out in in the snap of a
finger they're gone and now your arch
nemesis the one who killed so many
people the one who was responsible for
killing your parents and now he is
getting revived right in front of you
that is absolutely just ridiculously
terrifying I've got to put it at s tier
maybe even above Dumbledore dying maybe
even above dying very actually dying
blowing up ant Marge oh man okay after
all of these blowing up at March it's
like it's like way down here Moody's
death yeah that one was tough but
nowhere near as much as Dobby nowhere
near as Dumbledore definitely nowhere as
bad as Sirius but where does it rate in
terms of hedwig's death I mean the weird
thing is Harry didn't really know the
actual Moody he new a fake version of
Moody I think I'm gonna put this one
down here B tier Dementors in Surrey
okay this is when they attack Harry and
he's with Dudley by this point he knows
the Patronus charm he's able to use it
he's able to force them away still I
mean it's your worst fear so I kind of
want to put it at B tier yeah let's just
go and leave it at beat serious
destroying the fat lady's portrait
seat here the horcrux hunt oh man that's
right we moved it down here I mean if
we're talking about the entirety of the
horcrux hunt everything that they had to
go through that's got to be EST here
right gotta be all right just looking at
the S tiers here do we think that the
ministry battle plus Sirius is death
is the single most terrifying slash
traumatic see I almost wish they would
have included just one or the other
terrifying dramatic I don't know that it
was particularly terrifying it was
definitely the most traumatic though I
would say but terrifying see like the
graveyard for me would probably be the
more terrifying situation but when you
include the traumatic nature of it the
fact that Sirius died whereas in the
graveyard here Cedric died yeah I think
I feel solid about the S tears right
there I think I feel solid all right a
tier to mentors on the train I can see
why people would bump that down I can
but if you think about what that moment
served for Harry that was his first time
encountering them literally shapes the
rest of that book his entire school year
is really about the fact that he is
terrified of these Dementors simply
because it makes him relive his worst
fear which of course for Harry is way
more traumatic than anyone else because
of what happened to his parents he's
able to hear them and relive that moment
even though he was a baby oh okay this
is the only one like honestly like
looking at all of these other ones here
Ron leaving the horcrux hunt it almost
feels like it should be down here in the
B tier almost dude this is this is hard
this is crazy hard comment below let me
know what you guys think what are your s
tier ones did I miss any that you feel
like should definitely be an S tier let
me know in the comments YouTube happens
to think this video right here would be
awesome for you to watch next so check
that one out as always guys thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon